semi glutide or OIC and tepati or mouro
which are the they peptides but for
weight loss have just exploded to become
the number one prescribed drug in
America it is Hu number one now number
one it's huge and so I think the
pharmaceutical company said wow there's
something to these peptides as of last
week the FDA has reclassified most of
the peptides we use that they're no
longer going to be in use anymore the
the amount of money that's being made
from sell semi glutide and mouro is
massive so if they're thinking these are
peptides and now they look at the whole
Fleet of peptides and say wow there's a
world out there that we could tap into
and make it into a pharmaceutical I mean
again it's all big profit I don't know
if most people realize this when we
compound things we're able to do that at
a lesser cost to zepeti semaglutide for
most people their insurance is not
covering it's going to cost $1,500 a
month or more